in this video we'll talk about
salmonella and tarika and salmonellosis
salmonella enterika is a species of
bacteria that belongs to
enterobacteriacy family it's a
gram-negative rod-shaped bacterium and
it is one of the major cause of
foodborne illnesses worldwide
salmonella is responsible for the
salmonellosis disease which is
characterized by diarrhea abdominal
cramp fever and vomiting salmonella is
subdivided into two major species is
enterica and is bangori and it has more
than 200 2400 zero types generally
people confuse the name of the serotypes
with the subspecies so s enterica has a
serotype known as typhi which generally
people call as salmonella typhi and this
is the one of the most common cause of
salmonellosis
salmonella is one of the most common
foodborne pathogens and generally its
incidence is pretty high in South Asian
and African countries this particular
disease was first discovered and
observed by an American scientist known
as Dr Daniel Elmer Salman in 19th
century from his name it is known as
salmonella
it's gram negative its facultative
anaerobic meaning it can survive in both
aerobic and anaerobic condition and it
does not form spores let us talk about
the lab diagnosis so lab diagnosis
involves specific differential media so
such as SS media that is salmonella
shigella agar media and the colonies for
salmonella would appear as blackish just
like this plate and there is also
another test known as triple sugar iron
agar taste in this case H2S gas would be
produced and it would ultimately lead to
a black precipitate in the medium that
you can see here
anyway transmission of salmonella can
occur from contaminated food or
contaminated water source other than
that there could be fecal to oral
transmission imagine a vegetable field
is infected by Infested by some kind of
like fecal matter which has the
salmonella and if that vegetable is not
washed properly and somebody eats salads
out of it then he might get contaminated
other than that unpasteurized milk raw
meat contact with poultry animals or
from reptiles this can be transmitted
let's talk about the pathology
in order to understand that we have to
look at the intestinal histology a
little bit so this is how the intestinal
histology look like you have mucosa
submucosa muscularis and serosa so the
mucosal cells are generally infected by
the salmonella they uh engulf the
salmonella and Via endocytosis
eventually salmonella gets on the other
side into the submucosal surface where
macrophages actually uptake these
salmonella
so salmonella passed through the
endothelial cells in the submucosa and
are uptaken by the macrophages but
macrophages can grow in number and I
mean these Salmonella bacteria can grow
inside the macrophages as the
intracellular pathogen and then it can
ultimately go to the reticulo
endothelial system with the bacteria can
multiply and ultimately form lymphoid
hyperplasia or hypertrophy
also salmonella can re-entered the bowel
via liver or gallbladder that can
amplify the overall infection
also some amount of bacteria can be uh
engulfed by the macrophages which are
leading to which are giving rise to
specific kind of cytokines which are
pro-inflammatory in nature and this
would create inflammation in the
intestine and it lead to diarrhea and
abdominal cramp-like symptoms some of
the salmonella can enter the bloodstream
they can ultimately lead to bacteremia
ultimately this bacteria can go to
different organs such as lung heart and
liver and form focal salmonella
infection
now salmonella
and the symptoms of salmonella includes
nausea vomiting and
abdominal pain
other symptoms might include chill
anorexia and maculopapular rash but
these are not present in all the
patients
now the symptoms of salmon salmonella
infection occurs for 12 to 48 hours
after the exposure to pathogen and the
symptoms last typically for two to five
days before resolution
so it has to be treated properly with
antibiotic because otherwise it can
cause specific fever which might be
life-threatening treatment options
include specific antibiotics such as
ciprofloxacin azithromycin sulfur
methoxazole Etc other than that
replenishing the body fluid and
electrolyte is quite essential in K in
severe cases hospitalization might be
important and IV fluids can replenish
the proper balance of electrolytes in
the body so if you are infected with
salmonella consult a doctor asap
I hope this was useful get notes and
flashcards in my Facebook page or
Instagram page links are provided in the
description you can support our Channel
using super thanks you can contribute
via paytm PayPal or UPI so see you in
next video